This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
From BBC Learning English
Hello, this is 6 Minute English and I'm Catherine.
And I'm Sam.
No, Sam, have you been watching the World Cup?
Quick it or football?
Because they're both being played at the moment.
There they are now, I'm talking about football,
the Women's World Cup.
In that case, yes, I have.
I've really enjoyed it and it's been great that finally we can watch
the matches live on TV and that there's been so much interest in the media.
We'll be finding out a little bit more about the history of women's football
in England in today's programme.
But first, Sam, a question for you.
When was the first official women's football world cup?
Was it a 1970?
B1988 or C1991?
What do you think, Sam?
Well, I think I can get this through mathematics rather than knowledge.
So I'm not going to say it right now, but I'll tell you later.
Okay, well, I'll tell you the answer later in the programme.
Now, Jermic Locke is a writer on women's football in England
and she spoke recently on the BBC Women's Hour programme.
Here she describes the reaction throughout the years to women's football.
Has it been easy for the women's game in England?
Women's football has really been a struggle to play,
to have any kind of agency and to be taken seriously as athletes.
That can be seen throughout history.
I think every moment that women's football has had,
there's been a backlash afterwards or a kind of attempt to keep women back
and to dampen enthusiasm for the sport.
So it's not been easy, has it?
No, she said it's been a struggle,
which means it's been difficult to make any progress.
And she also mentioned that there was no agency in the women's game.
To have agency means you have control over your own situation.
You can make the decisions you want to make.
So she's saying that the women's game didn't really have control over its own future.
Every time they had some success, there was a backlash.
There was a negative reaction to their success.
That's right, and she goes on to say that people tried to dampen enthusiasm for the sport.
They tried to make it difficult to see and enjoy it.
So who tried to dampen enthusiasm and how do they do it?
Well, during that after the First World War, women's football became really popular with crowds of
up to 50,000 watching games.
It may have been popular with the crowds, but it wasn't so popular with the men who ran the game.
The English Football Association.
Here's Gemma Clock again.
The Men's Football Association were panicked by seeing women doing so well,
and they banned all women from playing football on association grounds,
and that lasted for about 50 years.
It was a very concerted effort to keep women's football amateur status
and ensure that there weren't crowds watching them play.
So the men were really worried by the success of the women's game.
They thought it might take money and supporters away from the men's game.
So they banned women from playing on their pitches.
This means that they no longer allowed them to use the pitches anymore.
This effectively killed the professional women's game.
As up to then, they'd been using the same facilities as the men.
This, she says, was a concerted effort to restrict women's football.
When you make a concerted effort to do something, it means that you try really hard to do it.
I'm pleased to say that the ban on women using football association pitches was eventually lifted,
although only comparatively recently in 1971.
Right, before we review today's vocabulary, let's have the answer to today's question.
So I asked you, Sam, when was the first official women's world cup?
Was it a 1970 B1988 or C1991?
And you said, Sam, you were going to work this out with maths.
So come on then.
I know. I did.
So I know the World Cup has held every four years.
It's 2019 now.
So the answer must be an odd year, very with me, which makes it 1991.
Am I right?
Right, well, we'll see if the mathematical approach is any better than you actually just knowing the answer.
The first World Cup for women was actually held in.
Oh, come on, hurry up.
Levin and my riddy.
19.
Oh no.
70.
Oh, I can't believe I got that wrong.
But it wasn't an official tournament.
The first official women's World Cup was indeed 1990.
Yay, it's a...
Your maths words.
So where does Sam and everybody else who got that right?
Now, before we get to extra time and penalties, let's recap today's vocabulary.
A struggle is how you can describe something that is very difficult to achieve,
something you have to fight for.
To have agency means being able to act independently and have control over your own choices.
A backlash is a strong negative reaction to something.
If you try to damp an enthusiasm for something, you try to make people less interested in it.
Banging something means using certain powers to stop something from happening.
And finally, making a concerted effort means trying really hard.
Well, the final whistle has blown for us today.
We'll see you again soon and don't forget to look out for more from the BBC Learning English team
online on social media and on our app.
Bye for now. Bye!